hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel in this tutorial we will
be learning java projects and java
interview questions but before we begin
let me tell you guys that we have day
layer based on multiple technologies so
if you're a tech geek in a continuous
hunt for latest technological trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn now without further
ado let's get started with the agenda
for today's session followed by the java
projects we will go through some
important java interview questions so i
hope i made myself clear with the agenda
now without further ado let's get
started with the java projects
over to our experts the top 10 java
project ideas
so the first project that we will deal
today is the online career management
system
so this particular project motto is to
deal with the career management system
the system will be used for day-to-day
activities like buy written booking
delivery and non-delivery and pickup etc
it is not easy to build this particular
project all alone as the technicality of
the project is a little complex for a
single programmer i would suggest you
that you get a team with you and also
look out for some automation in the
process by developing the relevant
software
robotic process automation is the new
normal in today's life the web enabled
interface allows the user to log in from
anywhere in the world and track their
career and also view the customer rating
the system is designed to integrate with
financial accounting to eliminate
duplication of data entry and is also
scalable to grow along with your company
the system needs to be built with
user-friendly screens rich in
functionality and features and finally
the major part it should maintain a high
level of data integrity
so with that abstract discussed now
let's look into the features offered by
this particular online courier service
as discussed in the abstract this
particular project should be providing
the features of order and dispatch of
the product information regarding the
customer delivery executive and followed
by the delivery executive we should be
also having a payment window which
manages the accounts and bill reports
so having said that let's now move into
the software requirements
so the software used in this particular
project is the programming language that
is java database is the microsoft access
and some convenient rpa tools and
finally the ide the id for this can be
any one which has a good support for
java the most preferable one would be
the eclipse and then comes the intellij
netbeans and many more now creating this
kind of a project will give you a
valuable experience based on building a
fully fledged e-commerce website or an
application
i mean this is how the world's leading
applications like amazon flip cards or
motto etc are basically planned and have
reached greater heights today this kind
of project on your resume could make a
huge difference and who knows tomorrow
you might even get into one of those
companies and start working on their
projects or
build a company of your own
followed by the online career system we
have the online voting system
now thinking apart from getting a job or
starting a new company of your own this
is something that we all need today in
this pandemic situation especially in
the current scenario the internet has
brought all the east to our living room
it has replaced physical banking to
internet banking ordering food online
buying movie tickets
buying clothes and household items to
consult your doctor for minor issues
bill payments and many more yet for
quite a long time going to polling booth
and standing in a long queue to cast a
vote has been persistent and it has been
challenging for the government to
motivate common people to participate in
the election system and cast their vote
just because there is no other way to do
such thing as such an online voting
system but all the credit can be
achieved by software engineers who can
make it possible soon for everyone to
cast their oat to their respective
candidate
as their own choice with an unmatchable
ease
this can be done just by click on their
fingers
this is an advanced java project
developed to show online voting
functionality followed by the abstract
we will get into the technicality of
this particular project so the first
phase of this particular project has the
admin phase where the admin has the
right to manage the candidates manage
the voters and their profiles and
passwords and finally election results
followed by the admin we have the voter
or the user of this particular
application the voter or the user gets
to register himself or herself into the
application followed by that he can use
the login and logout options and next we
have the profile and password
managements so followed by that we have
the option to choose the positions to
vote and finally to cast the vote now
this particular project is an advanced
level java project developed to show
online voting functionality it showcases
the use of java servlets html and css
again coming into the ide the ide for
this can be anyone who has good support
for java the most preferable one would
be eclipse and intellij
followed by the online voting system we
will now continue with the online
healthcare management
named as the corporate medicare
management this e-healthcare management
system is a web-based project developed
in java
the main aim of this particular project
is to provide effective management of
data related to staff and patients in
hospitals or clinics
the features offered by this particular
project should be as follows it should
optimize bed occupation the project
should improve the use of operation
theaters avoiding the cancellation of
operations to know how much emergencies
affect the administration of the
hospital departments or services which
include cancellation of operations
to optimize the allocation of human and
material resources to warts and shifts
to detect the influence of certain
diseases in the hospital services and
finally to find clusters of patients
the software requirement for this
particular project are as follows
we need dhtml for the front end
and java as the programming language
and data mining tool which is waka
and oracle for the database
javascript for the scripting language
and finally tomcat as our server the
e-healthcare management system is a
web-based application that assists the
management of staff doctors and patients
in an easy comfortable and effective way
here the concept of data mining plays a
vital route to develop an effective
health care management system
the proposed application aims to create
a friendly working environment for any
healthcare centers to overcome the
drawbacks in the existing system of
healthcare management
this system is very reliable and
flexible from all aspects so new
features and modules can be easily
integrated into the system in the future
followed by the e-healthcare management
system we have a new normal online
banking
not interesting and arousing for a
normal person but for a hardcore
programmer it is as exciting as a
rollercoaster ride in an amusement park
because this is how the major national
and multinational banks implement their
banking facilities in a wide range so
that their customers could experience
the ease of banking at their fingertips
one such type of project on your resume
could bring major highlight to the
recruiter especially if the recruiter is
from a banking or financial based
company
online banking system project is a model
internet banking site this project
should enable the customers to perform
basic bank transactions by sitting at a
corner of their home or office through a
phone or laptop the customers can access
bank's website for viewing their account
details and perform the transactions on
account as per the requirement bank
employees can login and add customer and
account information to perform
transactions with internet banking with
internet banking the brick and mortar
structure of the traditional bank gets
converted into a click and portal mode
thereby giving the concept of virtual
banking a real shape thus today's
banking is no longer confined to
branches
e-banking facilities banking
transactions by customers round the
clock globally the features you can
offer through this particular project
are
home page for online banking site
creation of new accounts login and log
out
manage profiles and passwords view the
balance of the account deposit the
amount into the selected account veteran
amount from the selected account
transfer the amount from one account to
another close the account so the
software requirements for this
particular project are java programming
language and and javascript for
scripting language and oracle for
database and tomcat for server
so followed by the online banking
project we have the online examination
project
online exams are normal for us nowadays
but this is totally limited to high-end
exams like cet gre cat etc the
requirement for this particular project
is increasing day by day because of the
current scenarios many schools and
colleges have now turned towards the
online education system and are looking
forward to hosting online exams for
student safety
online examination is a simple project
developed to provide an online platform
for faculty and students to conduct
online examinations and their
evaluations
this particular project has two parts
first is the admin part
admin has the right to add students
create one-time login
adding questions receive answers and
finally to evaluate followed by the
first part we have the second part which
belongs to the students
so the students can login update their
profile and password select answers for
the mcqs write answers to questions and
finally closing the session and logout
this particular project can be made a
grand success by making use of simple
java servlets and java programming
languages and server like apache tomcat
followed by the online examinations we
have the smart city smart city java
project can be a web-based software
developed to store the details of a
particular city the main purpose of the
project is to help tourists and other
visitors to a city by providing
information about hotels transportation
facilities air ticket booking shopping
details city news etc the smart city
java project serves the visitors as a
guide of the city and hence the project
is called as city guide project in java
using this project the details of the
city can be accessed from anywhere at
any time the implementation of the city
project promotes tourism and business
effectively
hotels can be searched more easily from
anywhere with the help of this online
software students can look out for
academic institutes located in the city
you can view the complete map of the
city using this project
followed by the abstract we have the
features of this particular project the
features offered in this particular
project are login update profile and
password search for the options select
an option like booking a ticket or hotel
or anything like
transportation etc and finally selecting
that particular option booking that
option and payment window finally the
confirmation of the order
this particular project can be fulfilled
by using the following software tools as
mentioned below
they are the java programming language
tomcat server scripting languages like
javascript etc and database as oracle
for interactive data storage
this could be escalated to another level
by following
designed drones that can act like a corp
act as a tourist guide for the people
touring the city a drone that has
capability to take pictures videos of
suspected activities and store it for
future reference a drone can intimidate
a cop if any suspected activities are
detected
there can be many drones in the city
with different functionalities and
finally you are required to implement
the functionality of the drone to the
users to interact with the drone users
could be travelers or corps or travel
agents or cab agents
the code for all these projects are
provided in the description box below
followed by the smart city we have the
bug tracking system
the bug tracking system is a web-based
application developed by java
programming language for software
companies
the main aim of this project is to
manage the errors or bugs that occur
during the software development phase
and cycle after the implementation of
this project the employees can update
the issue details solve the issues and
update the system for any location with
internet access
below are the features of this project
and source code of this project is
linked in the description box below
coming into features the software is
applicable in managing the bugs that
occur during the development of software
and tracking the older issues it
facilitates searching the facility to
bug history and solution the system is
fully secured and authentication method
is adopted
to manage security it stores the older
bug reports so that they can easily be
solved when they reappear the
application helps the project manager in
evaluating the works of the employees
and finally the proposed software is
capable of auto update when the latest
version is available
so the software requirements for this
particular project are
programming language which is java
web-based applications such as jdbc jndi
servlets jsp and oracle database or
access database as the database
followed by that the server deployment
is red hat jboss es etc and the client
side scripting as the javascript and the
id for this particular project would be
eclipse with all the my eclipse plugins
and finally the user interface can be
designed using html and css
so with this we can move ahead into the
next project which is the facial
recognition
the face recognition with opencv is an
open source computer vision library that
has tons of modules like object
detection face detection and augmented
reality
the major features that this particular
project offers are managing the user
faces facilitate face identification
easy login and log out store face ids
identify suspects with just images
enhanced way to find cyber criminals so
followed by the features now we should
look into the software requirements to
build this particular project so the
programming language we need for this
particular project is java and followed
by the programming language we need the
apache and framework
mingw64 and finally the cmake framework
so followed by the facial recognition
project we have the next project which
is the vehicle recognition
so java anpr is a number plate
recognition software which implements
algorithmic and mathematical principles
from artificial intelligence machine
vision and neural networks
so the features offered by this
particular project are high-level
language for numerical computation
interactive environment for iterative
exploration mathematical functions
built-in graphics functions for
integrating matlab and many more so this
particular project can be fulfilled by
using opencv and java programming
language along with some natural
language processing
algorithms so followed by vehicle
recognition project we have our last
project which is the speech recognition
system so speech recognizer converts
audio to text
java x dot speech dot recognition
package defines the recognizer interface
to build speech recognition plus a set
of supporting classes and interfaces
so the features or stages in this
particular project are to create a
speech recognizer allocate resources
load and enable grammar attach result
listener commit changes and finally
provide the process results
so this particular library is readily
available in java and you can code this
project using the java programming
language and an id such as eclipse so in
this session we are going to focus on a
particular project
and the project we are going to focus is
is about an atm application
so you might have interacted with
different atm stores in your cities
where you go in you insert your card you
enter your pin and then you can view the
balance you can withdraw some amount you
can also deposit some amount from the
atm
so we will try to look at it from that
perspective and we will see what kind of
different
uh java and oops concepts we can use to
build such atm application
this is not a super versatile
application but this is just to give you
the idea of how to use those oops
concepts to build a simple or a complex
java application so let's start from the
options menu class because that will
give us the understanding of what kind
of functionality i'm using
and here you will use that
i am using different concepts which i
have taught you so far in this
particular series
so for example we are using the io
exception we are using the hash map
class we are also using a scanner class
which is used to take input from the
command line
so this option menu class is extending
the account class and i will come to the
account class in a while but let's see
what this option menu class is doing
this particular class has uh it is using
a decimal format money format class
which is to denote what kind of
format of money you have then we have a
hash map which is storing the couple of
uh records of account number to pin
mapping so we create a map and inside
the get login method
we add couple of entries to the map
here the first entry the first integer
is pointing to the customer number
and the second integer is pointing to
the pin of the account of this
particular customer number
so if we call the get login method this
method will insert the data
after that it will ask the customer to
enter the customer number which has to
be one of these two
if you provide any other value then
there should be a logic in the
application to reject the input
so whatever a customer number the
customer inputs we pass that inside this
particular method called set customer
number
again i will come back to that
and once you have provided a valid
customer number then this method is
going to ask you to enter a pin number
and remember i told you this is the
customer number to the pin number
mapping
so whatever customer number you select
from here
you will be providing the corresponding
pin number and again if you provide an
invalid pin number you will get an error
so that will all happen inside this try
block and if you enter any invalid
characters in the pin number or the atm
customer number then you will get an
exception which i am writing inside the
catch block
this is all what we have seen so far
after the successful enter of the
customer number and the pin number i
fetch those values from these two
methods again i will talk about what
these methods are doing
and again i'm doing some basic
validation checks but things get
interesting in this method
so what we covered so far was the get
login method let me close this method
here
so we covered the get login method the
second method which is defined in this
particular class is the account type
so here that we will ask the once the
customer has provided the customer
number and the pin number we will ask
the customer to provide the account type
this application supports two different
account types which are checking account
or a savings account so whatever so the
customer has to choose one of them again
we will be taking the input from the
command line using the scanner class
and then i'm using a switch case if the
customer entered 1 then i will execute
some code for the checking account which
is defined here in the case 1
and if the customer entered two then the
case two will be executed
and if the if it enters three then i
will exit the application by just
printing a sys out
so here i'm using the switch case
construct to provide different options
to the customer
there's also a default case specified
here which says invalid choice
so this is what is happening in the get
account type method
the next method is if the customer has
used the option one then we call the get
checking method
so let's go to the get checking method
which is the next method which is
defined in this particular class
so if the customer has selected a
checking account then we provide the
following functionality to the customer
which is the customer can view the
balance
customer can withdraw the funds
customer can deposit the funds to the
checking account or they can just exit
the application
and again i'm using a switch case here
based on the customer types 1 2 3 or 4
the corresponding case block will be
executed
for example if the customer wants to
view the balance then this block will
get executed and i call the get account
type method
if the customer selects the
to as the withdraw fund then get
checkings with withdraw input method
gets called
and then get account type gets called
similarly if the customer enters three
then we deposit the fund and for that
also i have defined a method i will go
to the definition of these methods as we
go along but right now we are just
building the framework
so the get checking deposit input method
will be called whenever the customer
selects the option three
and for option four we just exit the
application
so this is what is happening in the get
checking method
now if from the account selection if the
customer selected second option which
was savings account then we were calling
get saving method
so this is where the get saving method
is defined
and again it is following the exact same
format as we saw in the get checking
method
where we present the following options
like viewing balance withdrawing the
funds and depositing the funds in the
savings account
and i have some methods defined here for
example get saving withdraw input
get saving deposit
input so we define the switch case here
based on the customer's choices here
and that is what is happening in the get
saving method so let me close this
method as well and that's all what is
defined inside the option menu class
so we ask the customer to enter the
customer number the pin number from this
get login method
then based on
that we provide
the customer the options to choose the
account type whether they can choose the
savings account or the checking account
and based on that whatever account type
they use
we call the get checking or get saving
method and inside this method we provide
the customer the other options to either
withdraw the money deposit the money or
view the balance
that is what is happening inside this
option menu class
now let's go to the account class and
all the methods which we saw here will
be provided a definition in the account
class
you also see this option menu is
extending the accounts class so an
inheritance concept is being used here
let's go to the account class now
so this is the account class where i
have defined some private member
variables like customer number so now
you will be familiar with the customer
number pin number which i just described
and also with the checking balance and
the savings balance
you can also divide this account class
into two child classes where you have a
savings account class and a checking
account class
but for simplicity i've kept it to one
class
i'm initializing a scanner input which
will be used at multiple places and then
i have the setters and getters for these
four
member variables so you see set customer
number get customer number
if you remember this set customer number
was called in the option menu class if i
go back to the get login
once we ask the customer to enter the
customer number
we call the set customer number
which gets called here
similarly
we call the set pin number
which gets called here
similarly once we have said that we then
we were fetching the values using the
get customer number and the get pin
number
and that has that is also defined here
in terms of the getters
get pin number and get customer number
similarly we also have the getters for
the checking balance and the saving
balance member variables
we do not have the setters for them
because they are not technically setters
but we have to calculate the balance
it's not a simple setter where you can
just return the value
so now let's look at some of the
business functions of the account class
how do you deposit how do you view the
balance how do you withdraw the balance
etc
so you see these two methods
which are specifically when the customer
is trying to withdraw the money from
their account
and these methods are basically called
internally by other methods so we will
come to that let's just understand that
we have two methods for calculating the
withdrawable amount or executing the
withdrawal transaction
for the checking account account and the
savings account
similarly i have two more methods here
which are calculating the depositing for
the checking account and calculating the
depositing for the savings account
and then we get the the bigger methods
which are using these calculation
methods so i define four calculation
methods so far
calc checking withdraw calc saving
withdraw
calc checking deposit and calc saving
deposit basically withdrawing and
deposit for both of the classes
and then we have these business
functions called get checking withdraw
input
and get saving withdraw input get
checking deposit input and get saving
deposit input
so these getter methods are something
which were being called from the option
menu class if you remember
if you go back to the option menu class
and if you chose the checking account
you get these options and let's say you
chose option two which was withdraw
funds or option three which was deposit
funds
then the corresponding methods which
were being called were get checking
withdraw input
and get checking deposit input
and this is the exact same method get
checking withdraw input
and
get checking deposit input
so if you see what is happening inside
this particular method is couple of
sysouts
then we
take the scanner input amount and we
convert that amount to the double
after that we check
if the amount which the customer wants
to withdraw is smaller than the checking
balance or not and i'm running this
condition to check that
if the amount is smaller than the
checking balance
then we call the calc checking withdraw
method
which was defined right here
remember i told you that these four calc
methods will be used and this is how
they are used so here i'm actually
subtracting the value so whatever amount
the customer wants to withdraw
subtract that from the main balance and
then return the new main balance
that's what you do right if you have
thousand rupees and if you want to
withdraw 500 you subtract 500 from
thousand and then you send back the
remaining balance
so that is what is happening when we
call this method and then we print the
new checking account balance
that is what is happening in the get
checking withdraw input method
similarly if you chose option 3 which
was
depositing funds to the checking account
then get checking deposit input gets
called
and it is defined right here
get checking deposit input and here
instead of subtraction
we are doing the addition
so here i am again doing a condition
check that the current balance plus the
new amount which has been supplied by
the customer from the command line
the total sum of it should be greater
than zero
what if the customer entered an amount
minus 5000 i should not allow that
so that's
the reason i'm putting this condition in
place
and if
the current balance plus the new amount
which is supposed to be deposited to the
account the sum of it is greater than
zero then call the calc checking deposit
method
and this is where the calc checking
deposit method is present and where i am
just doing present balance plus the new
amount and returning the new balance
that's all which is being done here
and you will see exactly similar logic
running for the
savings account as well
if you look at the get saving withdraw
input which is used to withdraw money
from the savings account so i take the
input from the command line and i run a
condition check that the amount which
the customer wants to withdraw
should be less than the current saving
accounts balance
if yes then call calc saving withdraw
method
which is defined here where i subtract
the amount from the current balance and
i return the new balance
and similarly you will see the exact
same functionality in the get saving
deposit where we add the money instead
of subtracting the money
and this is all what is defined in the
account class
so we talked about the option menu class
we talked about the account class and
now we have the atm class which is the
entry point which basically initializes
the option menu class and calls the get
login method
remember get login was the first method
which asked you to provide the customer
number and then get login called the
method to choose the account type and
the account type methods then called the
method to choose the option to withdraw
deposit or exit
so now we have built a fair
understanding of what is happening in
this application so let's run this
application
so i just ran this application and let
me bring the console here
it's first asking for a customer number
so i will go to the option menu class
and i will
pick up one of the customer number which
i have hard coded here
so i will provide that customer number
and hit enter
then it asks me for the pin number
so remember you have to provide the
correct pin number corresponding to the
customer number
so i'm taking this pin number just
copying it and pasting it here
then
this whole code got executed
and then it called the get account type
and the get account type method provided
you with these options which you see
here on the screen so based on what you
select the case block will get executed
and let's say i want to go for a
checking account so i press 1
and i hit enter
once you select the checking account the
case 1 gets selected and it calls the
get checking method
and the get checking method again
provides you with another menu view
withdraw or deposit or exit
so let's say i want to deposit funds so
i press 3
and hit enter
it says the current balance is 0
and enter the amount you want to deposit
let's say i want to deposit 500
and i hit enter
you get the message saying the new
checking account balance is 500 and you
have successfully deposited the money
and that is what i did for the checking
account
now let's try to withdraw something from
the ticking account so you again get
back the same option because inside the
get checking method
we call the once we have successfully
done the business operation we again
call the
account type method to display the menu
again to the user
so let's see again select the checking
account class
and this time i want to withdraw the
funds
remember i've added 500 there
so let's say i want to withdraw so i
choose the option 2 as the choice
current balance is 500 and it's asking
me the amount you want to withdraw from
the checking account
so i enter let's say 100 and i hit enter
when i do that the new checking account
balance becomes 400 so the 100 got
subtracted from the 500 and the new
balance is shown to your screen
you can do exactly the same thing for
for the savings account as well
and let's also run a negative condition
so i again select the checking account
and i want to withdraw the funds i
choose the option two
current balance is 400 and i i would
like to withdraw thousand
what happens
if you do that we get a message saying
balance cannot be negative and this is
coming from the calc checking method
which which is defined here so what is
happening that i wanted to withdraw the
funds from the checking account
and here get checking withdraw
input.called
here
this condition was checked
so the checking balance was
400
and the amount i wanted to withdraw was
1000 so 400 minus thousand is not
greater than equal to zero so it jumped
into the else block and it said balance
cannot be negative
so this is how you can also build some
error conditions in your code which are
mandatory and which should be built
otherwise your application will have lot
of bugs we can also exit the application
so if you just type three
and hit enter
you will exit from the application and
it will again call the login method
where it will again ask you to enter the
customer number
so this is how you can run this
application and this is this was a
simple use case for you to show how you
can use the different object-oriented
concepts like classes objects methods
setters getters switch case etc to build
the application with the correct
business logic
and this is all i want to cover in this
particular session
and in the next session we are going to
have a look at another interesting core
java project just to build our
understanding more better about the core
java concept choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
plus hours of video content for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
let's get started with walking through a
core java project using all the
different oops concept we have learned
so far
so in this example
we are going to have a look at a
calculator application and this
calculator application supports
primarily four different operations like
addition subtraction multiplication
and division
so let's see how do we build that app
so in front of me right now is open the
main class
so i have a main app class here which
has a public static void main method
and the first thing we see is a read
input class which is calling a read
method
so if you go to the read input class
it has a simple static method here which
is the read method
and it is using the scanner class
if you remember i talked about the
scanner class which is used to take
inputs from the command line from the
user
so
we initialize the scanner class and we
start taking the inputs
and whatever the user inputs in terms of
the expression let's say the user
entered 4 plus 5 or whatever that whole
expression gets sent back into this
input line as a string
and that comes back here in that input
expression
once we have captured the input
expression the next thing we do is
divide the input expression
in the numbers and the operators
basically an expression would be either
something like
4 plus 5
into 3
divided by 2 let's say
let's say the user entered this
expression so this has either numbers or
operators
so that's what we are doing here we are
using the split method of the string api
the string class basically
and this split method is going to split
the numbers and operators into two
different string arrays
and here i am providing the split
expression that split at every time you
encounter one of these symbols
so this when you execute this particular
statement it is going to return a
numbers array
which will be
created based on this expression so you
will get an array with four
five three and two
and similarly in the
operator array you are going to split
or pick out the elements every time you
receive a number so this operator array
is going to hold this plus sign
this multiply sign and this divide sign
hope you get the understanding that we
are just splitting the whole expression
into two different arrays
where first array is holding only the
numbers and no mathematical expressions
and second array is just holding the
mathematical operators and no numbers
and we'll see why we need to do that in
the upcoming lines
once i've created this string array i
just want to
store or convert these string arrays
into a queue
so i convert this
array into a list by calling the array
dot as list so this expression is going
to return a list
and then i am going to
convert this normal list
into a linked list
and then going to store this linked list
into the queue of numbers
and i'm going to do exactly the same
thing for the operator array as well
converting this into a generic list
converting that generic list into a
linked list
and then storing this linked list as a
queue
so i have an operators queue and i have
a numbers queue both of them have been
stored into a queue now
and then i'm using the poll method
if you remember the poll method of the
queue is used when you want to fetch the
first front element the head element of
the queue so whichever element is
sitting at the head of the queue will be
taken out the moment you call the
whole method
so i fetch the first
number from the numbers q
so in this case 4 will be fetched
here
in this variable
and after that i run a loop on the
numbers q and i'm going to run this
particular loop
till this particular queue
is not empty if you see there's a
negation here so i'm going to pick up
numbers one by one from this numbers q
till the number q becomes empty
and inside the loop
i do this exact same poll operation for
the operations queue so this operations
queue is holding all these mathematical
operations
like plus star and divide
so i'm going to pick the head of it
so in this case plus will be picked up
and will be stored in this variable
called opr
and then i'm going to run a switch case
on this opr
basically as i told you in this
particular calculator application
we are supporting four operations which
are addition
subtraction multiplication and division
so i define a case for each of the
mathematical expression
so you see there are four different
cases here
and for each case i'm initializing a
class if it's a plus sign then i'm
initializing the add class
if it's a minus sign then i'm
initializing the subtractors
for multiplication i have a class called
multiply and for division i have a class
called divide
let's have a look at what these classes
are containing
so if i go to the add class first of all
it is implementing an interface called
operate
and this operator interface has just a
single method called get results
which is accepting a variable argument
array if you remember i told you that
you can also use a wear arc array this
is called a arc expression this means
that this numbers will be an array of
arbitrary length it can be a one element
array it can be a two element array it
can be a four element array or whatever
you supply but it is still going to be a
fixed length array but the length is
going to be dependent upon how much
argument you supply to this particular
method
so that is what this interface operate
is doing it just has one method declared
which is called get result which is
accepting an array of numbers so
if the add class is implementing the
operate interface then it has to
override the get result method and here
it is just doing a summation of all the
numbers which have been supplied so if
you supply four numbers it is just going
to add up those four numbers and return
the sum
and
the exact same kind of logic or similar
logic will be seen in other
operate classes so if i go to the
subtract class
it runs the exact same operation but it
subtracts the values
if i go to the multiply class
it is also implementing the operate
interface and in the get result it is
just multiplying all the values
similarly in the divide class
it is also implementing the operator
interface and it is dividing all the
numbers one by one
so it's doing pretty much the same thing
in terms of the
expression and the logic
the only difference is whether you are
using an add operation or a subtract or
multiply or a divide
so we have checked all these classes and
the operator interface as well
and let's go back to the main app now
now you also see that i've defined a
reference of operate here and each of
the switch case block
i'm assigning
the object type to this interface
reference so i'm using the concept of
dynamic binding which we talked about
when we talked about interfaces
that we can also do dynamic binding
where we can assign an object
to an interface type
and the object type will depend upon the
expression
so once we have filled that based on the
case
while
filtering out this expression and
picking up plus star and divide
sequentially
then we go to the next line outside the
switch case block which is to pick the
next
number from the queue
remember we already did one poll here
so as per this example 4 was here in
this res
and now when we do this number dot poll
again
5 will be picked up because that will be
the next head of the queue
so we pick up 5 here
and then we call operate dot get result
now this get result will be called based
on the expression which was encountered
first in the queue
again looking at the example the first
expression encountered will be plus
so the expression was plus so the
operate type object is of add type
and when you call operate dot get result
the get result method of add class is
going to get invoked
and it is going to sum 4 and 5. this res
is holding 4 right now
based on what i described here numbers
dot poll
and this num is holding
the
the second operand basically
basically 5 here so 4 plus 5 gets
evaluated here in this case
and then it again goes back here and it
checks if the number queue is now empty
no it is still not empty because we
still have 3n2
left there
so
again it does the operations.poll
and it picks up multiply sign here
then it again runs the switch case since
it's a multiply sign it will go here and
it will initialize the operate interface
reference as the object of multiply
class
then coming here it will do a numbers
dot poll and this time the numbers dot
poll is going to pick up 3
so 3 will be picked up here
and then the current value of result
which is already 9
4 plus 5 was 9 the current value of
result will be updated here so rest will
be 9 here and num will be 3 here and
when you call operate dot get result the
multiply classes get result will get
called and it will say 9 into 3
which will become 27
it will again go back here to this
particular line and it will check again
if the numbers queue is now empty no it
is still not empty because we still have
one element left
then it pulls uh the queue of the
operations where the expression divide
is present there which is the only
element left in this particular
operations queue
and since we have the opr value as
divide
this case block gets called and the new
divide class gets initialized the divide
class basically gets initialized
and
we come here and we do numbers dot poll
now the last number which is available
in this queue is 2 which gets picked up
here
and then we again call operate.getresult
this time since the operate object refer
object operate reference type was of
divide class type
so when we call operate.getresult
the divide operation or the get result
method of the divide class
basically this method will get invoked
and it will divide the current value of
result which was
4 plus 5 9 into 3 which was 27
so it is going to divide 27
by
2 which was the last value of the
numbers dot pole
it is going to execute 27 by 2 and
whatever value it gets it is going to
store a value back into the rest
variable and then it is again going to
go back here
and again going to check the condition
if the numbers q is
not empty but now the numbers q is empty
because 2 was the last element so it is
going to come out of the loop and it is
going to print the final result
that is how this whole program is
working
now let's try to see this in action and
will try to execute the exact same
expression
so if i right click and go to run as and
run this as java application
and i supply an expression saying 4 plus
5
star 3
divide 2
and if i now hit enter
i get the value as 13.5 which is exactly
what we ran through because 4 plus 5
will be evaluated first which will
result into 9
then 9 into 3 will be 27 and 27 divided
by 2 will be 13.5 exactly so this is how
this whole program is running where we
first take the inputs and then we divide
the input into numbers and operation
arrays or in fact queues
and once we have those queues built up
then we pick up the first number
and we keep running this loop till the
numbers q is not empty
inside the while loop at each step
we pick up the first expression or the
operator we check what is the operator
whether it is an addition subtraction
multiplication or division operator and
whatever kind of operator we have we
initialize the corresponding class of it
and then we
fetch the next
value in the numbers q and then we call
the get result based on the expression
and whatever result we get from the get
result we store it back into the rest
variable so we keep updating the rest
variable at every step
that's the reason the result of 4 plus 5
gets stored in the rest and next time
you are calling the get result for a
multiply operation here the rest value
is 9 now and it says 9 into 3 again in
the next time the rest value will be
updated to 27 because we are storing the
result back into the result variable
so this is all i want to cover in this
particular session where we looked at an
example of a calculator application
purely from the console standpoint
obviously there can be lot more stuff
which we can do into this particular
application make it more error free and
cover a lot of corner cases like
validating the inputs etc
also
looking at or putting some conditions
around the exception handling handling
the divide by zero scenario etc which is
not here but this is just to show you
the basic idea of how you can build
simple to complex cli applications using
the core java concepts
so in this example we are going to have
a look at a calculator application
and this calculator application supports
primarily four different operations like
addition subtraction multiplication and
division so let's see how do we build
that app so in front of me right now is
open the main class so i have a main app
class here which has a public static
void main method and the first thing we
see is a read input class which is
calling a read method so if you go to
the read input class it has a simple
static method here which is the read
method and it is using the scanner class
if you remember i talked about the
scanner class which is used to take
inputs from the command line from the
user so we initialize the scanner class
and we start taking the inputs and
whatever the user inputs in terms of the
expression let's say the user entered
four plus five or whatever that whole
expression gets sent back into this
input line as a string and that comes
back here in that input expression once
we have captured the input expression
the next thing we do is divide the input
expression in the numbers and the
operators
basically an expression would be either
something like
4 plus 5
into 3
divided by 2 let's say let's say the
user entered this expression so this has
either numbers or operators
so that's what we are doing here we are
using the split method of the string api
the string class basically
and this split method is going to split
the numbers and operators into two
different string arrays and here i'm
providing the split expression that
split at every time you encounter one of
these symbols so this when you execute
this particular statement it is going to
return a numbers array which will be uh
created based on this expression so you
will get an array with 4 5 3 and 2.
and similarly in the
operator array you are going to split or
pick out the elements every time you
receive a number so this operator array
is going to hold this plus sign this
multiply sign and this divide sign hope
you get the understanding that we are
just splitting the whole expression into
two different arrays where first array
is holding only the numbers and no
mathematical expressions and second
array is just holding the mathematical
operators and no numbers
and we'll see why we need to do that in
the upcoming lines
once i've created the string array i
just want to store or convert these
string arrays into a queue so i convert
this array into a list by calling the
array dot as list so this expression is
going to return a list
and then i'm going to convert this
normal list into a linked list and then
going to store this link list into the
queue of numbers and i'm going to do
exactly the same thing for the operator
array as well converting this into a
generic list converting that generic
list into a linked list and then storing
this linked list as a queue so i have an
operators skew and i have a numbers
queue both of them have been stored into
a queue now and then i'm using the pole
method if you remember the pole method
of the queue is used when you want to
fetch the first front element the head
element of the queue so whichever
element is sitting at the head of the
queue will be taken out the moment you
call call the poll method
so i fetch the first number from the
numbers q so in this case 4 will be
fetched here in this variable
and after that i run a loop on the
numbers q and i'm going to run this
particular loop till this particular
queue is not empty if you see there's a
negation here so i'm going to pick up
numbers one by one from this numbers
queue till the number q becomes empty
and inside the loop i do this exact same
poll operation for the operations queue
so this operations queue is holding all
these mathematical operations
like plus star and divide so i'm going
to pick the head of it so in this case
plus will be picked up and will be
stored in this variable called opr and
then i'm going to run a switch case on
this opr basically as i told you in this
particular calculator application we are
supporting four operations which are
addition subtraction multiplication and
division so i define a case for each of
the mathematical expression
so you see there are four different
cases here and for each case i'm
initializing a class if it's a plus sign
then i'm initializing the add class if
it's a minus sign then i'm initializing
the subtractors for multiplication i
have a class called multiply and for
division i have a class called divide
let's have a look at what these classes
are containing so if i go to the add
class first of all it is implementing an
interface called operate
and this operator interface has just a
single method called get results
which is accepting a variable argument
array if you remember i told you that
you can also use a var arg array this is
called a where arc expression this means
that this numbers will be an array of
arbitrary length it can be a one element
array it can be a two element array it
can be a four element array or whatever
you supply but it is still going to be a
fixed length array but the length is
going to be dependent upon how much
argument you supply to this particular
method so that is what this interface
operate is doing it's it just has one
method declared which is called get
result which is accepting an array of
numbers
so
if the add class is implementing the
operate interface then it has to
override the get result method and here
it is just doing a summation of all the
numbers which have been supplied so if
you supply four numbers it is just going
to add up those four numbers and return
the sum
and the exact same kind of logic or
similar logic will be seen in other
operate classes so if i go to the
subtract class it runs the exact same
operation but it subtracts the values if
i go to the multiply class it is also
implementing the operate interface and
in the get result it is just multiplying
all the values
similarly in the divide class it is also
implementing the operator interface and
it is dividing all the numbers one by
one so it's doing pretty much the same
thing in terms of the
expression and the logic the only
difference is whether you are using an
add operation or a subtract or multiply
or a divide
so we have checked all these classes and
the operator interface as well and let's
go back to the main app now now you also
see that i've defined a reference of
operate here and each of this switch
case block i'm assigning the object type
to this interface reference so i'm using
the concept of dynamic binding which we
talked about when we talked about
interfaces that we can also do dynamic
binding where we can assign an object to
an interface type and the object type
will depend upon the expression so once
we have filled that based on the case
while filtering out this expression and
picking up plus star and divide
sequentially then we go to the next line
outside the switch case block which is
to pick the next number from the queue
remember we already did one poll here
so as per this example 4 was here in
this rest
and now when we do this number dot poll
again
5 will be picked up because that will be
the next head of the queue so we pick up
5 here and then we call operate dot get
result now this get result will be
called based on the expression which was
encountered first in the queue again
looking at the example the first
expression encountered will be plus
so the expression was plus so the
operate type object is of add type
and when you call operate dot get result
the get result method of add class is
going to get invoked and it is going to
sum 4 and 5. this rest is holding 4
right now based on what i described here
numbers dot poll
and this num is holding the
the second operand basically basically 5
here so 4 plus 5 gets evaluated here in
this case and then it again goes back
here and it checks if the number queue
is now empty no it is still not empty
because we still have three n2 left
there so
again it does the operations dot poll
and it picks up multiply sign here
then it again runs the switch case since
it's a multiply sign it will go here and
it will initialize the operate interface
reference as the object of multiply
class then coming here it will do a
numbers dot poll and this time the
numbers.poll is going to pick up 3 so 3
will be picked up here and then the
current value of result which is already
9 4 plus 5 was 9 the current value of
result will be updated here so rest will
be 9 here and num will be 3 here and
when you call operate.getresult the
multiply classes get result will get
called and it will say 9 into 3 which
will become 27 it will again go back
here to this particular line and it will
check again if the number skew is now
empty no it is still not empty because
we still have one element left
then it pulls
the queue of the operations where the
expression divide is present there which
is the only element left in this
particular operations queue and since we
have the opr value as divide this case
block gets called and the new divide
class gets initialized the divide class
basically gets initialized and we come
here and we do numbers.poll now the last
number which is available in this queue
is 2 which gets picked up here and then
we again call
operate.getresult this time since the
operate object refer object operate
reference type was of divide class type
so when we call operate.getresult the
divide operation or the get result
method of the divide class basically
this method will get invoked and it will
divide the current value of result which
was 4 plus 5 9 into 3 which was 27 so it
is going to divide 27 by 2 which was the
last value of the numbers dot poll so it
is it is going to execute 27 by 2 and
whatever value it gets it is going to
store the value back into the rest
variable and then it is again going to
go back here and again going to check
the condition if the numbers queue is
not empty but now the numbers q is empty
because 2 was the last element so it is
going to come out of the loop and it is
going to print the final result that is
how this whole program is working now
let's try to see this in action and
we'll try to execute the exact same
expression
so if i right click and go to run as and
run this as java application
and i supply an expression saying 4 plus
5
star
3 divide 2
and if i now hit enter i get the value
as 13.5 which is exactly what we ran
through because 4 plus 5 will be
evaluated first which will result into 9
then 9 into 3 will be 27 and 27 divided
by 2 will be 13.5 exactly so this is how
this whole program is running where we
first take the inputs and then we divide
the input into numbers and operation
arrays or in fact queues and once we
have those queues built up then we pick
up the first number and we keep running
this loop till the numbers q is not
empty inside the while loop at each step
we pick up the first expression or the
operator we check what is the operator
whether it is an addition subtraction
multiplication or division operator and
whatever kind of operator we have we
initialize the corresponding class of it
and then we
fetch the next value in the numbers q
and then we call the get result based on
the expression and whatever result we
get from the get result we store it back
into the rest variable so we keep
updating the rest variable at every step
that's the reason the result of 4 plus 5
gets stored in the rest and next time
you are calling the get result for a
multiply operation here the rest value
is 9 now and it says 9 into 3 again in
the next time the rest value will be
updated to 27 because we are storing the
result back into the result variable
so this is all i want to cover in this
particular session where we looked at an
example of a calculator application
purely from the console standpoint
obviously there can be lot more stuff
which we can do into this particular
application make it more error free and
cover a lot of corner cases like
validating the inputs etc also
looking at or putting some conditions
around the exception handling handling
the divide by zero scenario etc which is
not here but this is just to show you
the basic idea of how you can build
simple to complex cli applications using
the core java concepts let's get started
with spring boot and how we can build a
simple application using spring boot
before we go further let's understand
why we need spring boot and the basic
idea of spring boot is to build restful
web services if you want to know more
about what are restful services please
you can read about the restful concept
as a concept what does rest stand for
but the basic idea is that if you are
accessing anything over http then that
particular component can be built as a
restful component and spring boot is the
most popular choice for building restful
web services today and even in fact
micro services which you might have
heard about so you can build micro
services which also run on https using
spring boot so what i'm showing you
right now is the official guide of
spring which you can use to build an
application with spring boot it will
list down all the requisites which you
need in terms of the
jdk installations maven on and how to
complete this guide etc etc you can
again use the same springs initializer
which i talked about in the previous
session you can use this to generate a
spring boot project for you specifically
so all those options are available here
so i've already done that and i'm not
going to repeat what i just did in the
previous session and will directly jump
to an ide where i have created a sample
spring boot application and the
structure here you can see the structure
would look very similar with one change
that in the previous example when we
were dealing with mbc we had an src main
resources folder and that src main
resources folder was having all the web
components or the htmls but since in
restful web services you do not render
the html but you just send back the
response the response can be the
response body can be pure xml or it can
be pure json but you do not send back
and view and that's the main difference
between spring mvc and spring boot that
in spring mvc it will you are required
to return a view technology like in the
in the previous session we sent a dye my
life template which is basically in html
you can also written a gsp but with
spring boot you do not deal with the
view technology and that's the world we
are living in today when you write
spring boot you do not have to worry
about how this is going to be rendered
on the web page whether it is going to
be rendered using html or what not what
you need to take care of using spring
boot is to return the right response
body the exact text of the response and
that's it so with that in mind the
spring boot was born and the structure
apart from that the structure would look
very similar there's a palm.xml here
which will provide all the list of jars
and dependencies which are required for
this particular project so you can see
all the dependencies here pretty much
the similar ones we have a starter web
we have a starters test and we have a
spring boot maven plugin and we have an
application file which is the entry
point again having a public static void
main method so you need to put the at
the red spring boot application at the
top of the class to make it an entry
point if you don't do this spring boot
will not run this class and springboard
will
even not run your application so what we
are doing as part of this example that
we are just printing all the beans which
are provided by spring that's all we are
doing like i said it's a very
lightweight and the introductory session
so we will keep the logics to minimum
and i'm just getting all the bean
definitions sorting the bean definitions
and just printing them one by one how do
you get the bean definition you get that
with this application context class
which is returned when you run the
application and how you run the
application is basically using this line
where you say spring application dot run
and you supply application dot class
with any command line arguments which
you might want to use once you do this
it is going to return an application
context object to you and the
application context object can be used
to get all the bean definitions by
calling this method which says get bean
definition names so that's the basic
logic which is being run in the main
class now we also have a controller but
this time it's not a web controller but
it's a rest controller so you see in the
previous example we just had written
something like this it was just a pure
controller but here we have become more
specific we are saying that hey this is
not a simple mvc controller but this is
a spring boot controller or technically
a rest controller so spring provides a
separate annotation for that which is at
the rate rest controller so you write
that particular annotation or that on
the top of the controller class which
you are creating and then you provide a
request mapping similar to what we did
in spring mvc but while you return it
you do not return a view technology you
just return the raw response here i'm
just returning a string but you can
return a json object you can return an
xml object or whatever you want to but
not a view technology that's what i'm
doing like like you can see there's
literally nothing i'm doing in this it's
just a simple
string return statement which i have
printed here and that's all the code i
have right now here i just have these
two classes okay so that was all about
what i have written in the project and
now it's time to run the project so i
have just reached to the location on
inside my terminal where the project
bomb.xml was present and if i just do an
ls you will see that there is a pom.xml
available here and all the code direct
is also available here so now i will
just run this application
and to run this application i'm just
going to type mvn spring hyphen boot
colon run and hit enter once i do that
the spring application is going to
spring boot application is going to get
started and let's go back to uh the
controller and actually the main app
main end point and see what we were
doing there i did a cis out here which
said let's inspect the beans provided by
spring boot and then i was printing all
the bean names and if i go back to the
output i will see the same line being
written here which was around let's
inspect the beans so you can see that
message which says let's inspect the
beans provided by spring boot and then
all the beans which are available in the
application context are printed here so
that's that's the basic idea which i
want to give you that you can actually
build a spring boot application and you
can write your rest controllers return a
string body from it and once this is run
then you can also run your application
for from the web browser as well so
let's try to hit that particular url
which i wrote here so the url of hello
count so for that let me just open a new
cognito window and our application is
already running so if i just say http
localhost 8080 slash i get this message
here which says greetings from spring
boot and this is the message which we
were sending from the rest controller so
this validates our understanding that we
can invoke a crest controller which is a
spring boot rest controller via the same
method but this time we are not getting
an html but we are just returning this
particular string now you can use the
string in any ways you want so it
depends upon the consumer so that's all
i want to cover as part of the spring
boot now spring boot is a huge huge
topic and we can spend hours and hours
talking about spring boot but since this
is more of an introductory session so i
just wanted the concept to get
introduced and remember the value
proposition of why you would need spring
boot the basic idea is to build restful
web services or build restful micro
services that's the basic idea behind
using spring boot in your applications
and also remember the difference between
web mvc update spring mvc application
and spring boot application spring mvc
is for building web application spring
boot is for building restful
applications which might not have a web
interface integrated with them at that
moment let's get started with our demo
of a project which is using spring boot
to build a restful web service so a
restful web service is nothing but any
end point which you can access or you
can consume the data from via an http
layer or via a simply a web layer
because most of the web traffic which we
deal with is built on http so to take an
example if you go to any website where
you sometimes see on the top right
corner you see today's weather so how is
that today's weather coming in it's
coming in via a rest web service the
website which you are accessing is
basically hitting an http endpoint
which is uh where the where the weather
application is sitting and it asks for
the weather data and the dressed web
application just returns the data and
that's how the website is able to show
you the current weather so restful web
services are everywhere and they are the
most popular way to build applications
today where you just build your restful
web service and you expose an http url
and then the consumers need to just
access that http url to consume the data
from your application and you see this
makes it very easy because there is no
data type restrictions there is no tight
coupling here it's just an http endpoint
so that's the basic idea and we will
look at a project where we will be using
spring boot to build a restful web
service and then we will try to run that
web service to save some data and also
to return some data so here on the on
the package explorer you see i have
created a project called rest service
and let's just walk through the
structure of it and then we'll go into
the details of it so we have an src main
java where i have a package and i have
bunch of classes here and before we go
to the classes let's first also access
the dependency file because every
project
needs some dependencies some jars to
execute it for example spring itself is
basically a jar so you need to include
the spring jar in your project so that
your project can become a spring project
and there are generally two dependency
tools one is maven and one is gradle in
this particular project i am using maven
dependency tool for downloading and
managing the dependencies which are
needed to run this project successfully
and the way you will find if it's a
maven project or if it's a gradle
project for a maven project you will see
a file called
pom.xml pom.xml and if it's a gradle
project you will see a dot gradle file
that's how you can spot whether the
project is using maven for dependency
management or it is using gradle for
dependency management so let's open the
palm.xml since it's an xml file it will
be a bit verbose but
if you just read it piece by piece it
will become easier to understand first
of all since this is a spring project i
need to include the parent dependency
which brings lot of good defaults
sensible defaults from spring boot
automatically and this is the jar name
this is the artifact id which is spring
boot starter parent so any spring boot
project you are starting do include this
parent this parent is basically bringing
all the dependencies from some other jar
and you can make your project as a as a
child of this particular parent so all
the spring
board projects have this as a parent as
a standard practice after that you
provide your own details in terms of
what is the package name how do you want
to see the jar name on what is the jar
actual name what is the jar version etc
etc you also set the minimum required
java version to run this application and
then you in the dependency sections you
provide all the jars which you need to
run your project successfully both
compile and run your project
successfully so we added the spring boot
starter web on dependency which
basically brings all the dependencies
around making a controller or making a
repository
context component scan all the
interesting features which spring
provides get wrapped up inside the
spring boot starter jar and you can
actually go to the mvn repository and
and have a look at what all classes it
provides it's a lot of classes so i'm
just telling you in a brief that it
provides all the restful functionality
then you have the next dependency as
spring boot starter data jpa which is
going to enable this project to also
have a database and if it has a database
then you need java to talk to the
database and the way spring suggests to
talk to the database is why are using
the spring boot data jpl library we will
see this how this library can be used
but basically this provides ways to
represent your java object in the
database and then you need to also add
the actual dependency of the database
and in this case we are using an
in-memory h2 database so i'm not using
an external database like mysql or
oracle or post sql because that will
just make more configurations more
complicated i just wanted to keep it
simple and generally you in this h2
database you can easily access by adding
this dependency and it will be an
in-memory database created for you then
i've also added a string boot starter
test here which will be used whenever
you are writing unit tests and you must
write unit test for your project and
then we need to add the plugin so that
spring boot can run this project that's
all i have in the palm.xml now let's
move to the interesting part the java
section part let's start from the main
class
so this is how the main class looks like
where you have you just create
any any name with the class and then you
add a public static void main method
inside the public static void main
method you call spring application dot
run and this run method is basically
going to run your application and you
just provide the same class name which
you just wrote here so just say dot
class and if you're supplying any
command line arguments it can interpret
that command line arguments as well if
you want so you always need an entry
point in an application and this is the
entry point which spring boot supports
and this is if you see this code this is
just normal code to make spring be aware
about this class being treated as an
entry point you need to add add the red
spring boot application annotation on
top of the class this is one of the
annotation which is coming directly from
the spring boot library you can see this
import so once you add this then only
spring will be able to treat this class
as an entry point otherwise spring
doesn't know where to start from so when
you run spring it will fi it will try to
find a class with an annotation spring
boot application and then inside the
class it will try to find a public start
a static void main method and once it
has found both of them then it will just
run the application so very simple
nothing fancy here and what we are
dealing with here is a student object so
we will try to insert the student object
and we will try to retrieve the student
object so
if you ignore these annotations which
i've added it's just a pure pojo it's
just a plain old java object you create
a student class let's ignore this field
as well for now i'll just come back to
this annotation in this field but this
is just a student class it has three
fields as name agent address an empty
constructor and a parameterized
constructor and some getters
intentionally i have removed the setters
because generally whenever you are
building any enterprise grade
application you would like to keep your
objects immutable means once they have
been created you would not like somebody
to allow to change the values of the
object this just makes programming but
much more easy if you treat all the
objects in your application as immutable
that's why i have not added setters here
it's just considered a good practice so
apart from the standard things which we
have already seen there are two things
here which i want to talk about let's
first talk about this one so accurate
entity is the annotation which is coming
from java x persistent entity
persistence entity and this makes
spring boot save this particular object
into the database this is the annotation
which you need to put on your class so
that spring boot knows that this class
represents a table in the database so
you need to add this to make sure that
this represents a table second thing a
table will have a id it will have sort
of a primary key so i've created a new
column called id which is basically
representing the student's role number
or something or maybe a registration
number and here i'm using couple of more
annotations if you see these annotations
are also coming from java x persistence
library and these annotations will
basically allow the a new id to be
created every time you create a student
object so you don't have to specify the
value of this id variable springboot
will automatically generate a new id
value every time you create a new
student object and how does it generate
you you can provide the generation type
as well so currently i've just said that
set it as automatic but you can set it
as identity sequence or rate or
controlled by table you can also see the
explanation of each of these here but
i've just kept it as auto which
basically uh let the persistence
provider pick any appropriate strategy
for the particular database in our case
the database is h2 so that's about the
entity class let's call this as entity
class now let's move to the repository
so you need a repository class
like i explained in dots in that three
tier architecture you always need a dow
layer or a repository layer to store
your student object into the database so
we have enabled the student object to be
saved but we need a handler which can
save this particular file this
particular object into the database and
the repository classes are the classes
which will allow you to do that so you
create a very simple interface you what
you name whatever you want to name your
interface as and then you say extends
jpa repository the type of the object
and the unique identifier of the object
so the type of the object student here
and the unique identifier of the student
object is the id which is of type long
so you need to just supply the types
type of the object type of the primary
key or the type of the unique identifier
and this annotation is coming from
spring boot you can see specifically
spring boot data library which we added
so you just need to create an interface
extend it from jp repository and make
sure that you add this annotation as
well spring heavily uses the concept of
annotations and this will help spring
understand that this is a repository
layer class and it will apply some more
metadata to this class while this class
is running in the jvm so what happens
here you just created an interface you
did not provide any method to create or
any method to delete or any method to
get a student object because all of that
is automatically provided by springboot
via the jpa repository class if we go
inside this class and if you scroll down
you'll see the find all method find all
find all by id save all flush save and
flush delete etc and if you go further
up this also extends the paging and
sorting repository which provides
pagination and sorting facilities but
the interesting one is that pages and
sorting repository again extends a crud
repository and if you go to the crud
repository you will find all the basic
methods to save an entity save multiple
entities find an entity by the id that's
why it needed that long type to make
sure this that it can execute this
method you can check the existence of an
object find all the entries find all by
id count them delete them so all the
basic crud functionality so we call them
as crud because the reason it is called
crud because create read update delete
that's the basically the
generic acronym so because uh this
credit repository provides all the
methods and their implementations
automatically we do not need to write
any code at all so that's why springboot
is so awesome and that's why springboard
is very popular because it's zero code
in the repository and you still get all
the crud functionality so that's about
repository now we have covered the
entity class we have covered the
repository class we have covered the
entry point class now the only thing
which is remaining is the is the end
point the http endpoint which i talked
about and that you can create by
creating any class generally try to
suffix it with the controller so that
your core developers can easily find
this class and make sure that you put
add the red rest controller annotation
on top of it this annotation will allow
spring to treat this particular class as
an endpoint class then you can auto wire
the student repository so if you
remember i talked about the whole
dependency injection and inversion of
control so here dependency injection is
in action so here you are just telling
student controller to auto wire the
student repository and now what will
happen that at runtime student
controller or actually spring will
automatically create an object of the
student repository and supply that
object of student repository to student
controller so you as developer do not
have to create an object of student
repository explicitly that's the benefit
and that's how the dependency injection
is working because you inverted the
dependencies now the dependency is just
injected into the class and as a
developer you don't have to take control
of creating the objects it's the spring
which will automatically
read the autobot annotation and will
automatically supply an object whenever
it is required then i have two methods
here since we are talking about http
endpoints so i have represented a post
method here and a get method here the
way you will write a post method is via
at the rate post mapping annotation and
then you can provide the url path on
which somebody should call your end
point to save something so for example
somebody can call it http localhost 8080
student slash create whenever they hit
that url the control or that request
will directly hit this particular method
why because you have provided the url
mapping here in the post mapping
annotation so since it's a post method
there would be request body what is the
actual request body which the client is
sending and you can represent its uh
request body with the add direct request
body annotation and you can provide the
type of the request body and here i'm
saying that hey if you want to access
this particular url yes all good but you
need to supply me with a
text representation of the student
object or a json representation of the
student object and then i inside the
method i'm calling student repository
dot save which is going to save the
student object which is coming in so you
see there's a lot going on here i will i
will show you how the student is
represented in the request body as well
and then i will come back to how it got
converted from json to java but this is
how you can store this particular
student object you can hit this api as
many times as you want and keep
inserting a new student object every
time then if you want to fetch a
particular student then you can do that
by supplying the slash student and then
in the curly braces there's an id
written here so basically you can supply
the value of the id of the student so
generally there would be another method
here which would be find all to see all
the students uh and with their id and
then you can pick a particular student's
id supply that student id value here
dynamically that's why at the curly
braces curly braces supports dynamic
value so here it can insert 1 2 3 or
whatever the student id you want to
fetch the value for you provide that
value in the student slash id and all
good then some if somebody is hitting
the url with saying localhost 8080 slash
student slash 1 then student with the id
1 will be returned from the request and
you need to put ad direct get mapping to
make sure that this method is treated as
an http get method and you can provide
the type you can say get student and
here this dynamic value is captured with
the add the rate path variable because
you need to know the id right whatever
id somebody has supplied it in the url
you need to capture that ide and then
use that ide for calling the repository
so that's you can do that by using the
add variate path variable so here i'm
just saying whatever id is coming in i
will store that value inside this ide
once i've done that then i can again
call student repository dot find by id
which is again a built-in method
provided to me by the crud repository i
can supply the id and this actually is
going to return an optional object which
is uh which is an object which may or
may not contain a value so it said just
a types of a defensive programming style
so this will return an optional and you
can call a get method to return the
actual student object this will return
an optional of student so option of
student means that this optional object
may have a student or may not have a
student why did spring do that because
the id somebody is supplying that id can
be invalid also right so optional object
tree takes care of that that if there is
no student found then you will not get a
null pointer exception and if there's a
student found you can return that so
it's just a defensive programming style
which spring has adopted by returning an
optional of the student object rather
than directly the student object but if
you are confident that this particular
option of student object does contain a
student object then just call
optional.get which i've called here
which will return the actual student
object sitting inside the optional
object you can read more about the
optional object and its usage from the
official java docs and there are tons of
examples available on it on internet so
this is about the controller we have
covered all the classes now it's time to
run the application so you go to the
command prompt you go to the particular
file folder location and there
you just say mvn spring hyphen boot
colon run so i just hit enter and this
is going to
run the application it's going to split
some logs here and if everything is fine
you will not get an error and you will
just be getting a message saying that
application got started and it's running
on tomcat localhost 8080 with no context
url so this is not a web application
this is a rest full web service right
this is a restful service this is not a
web application so there is no web
interface so how do you access this you
just have an http url so you can use any
of the rest client available on the
internet there are probably hundreds of
different clients available on the
internet you can choose any one of them
i am using advanced rest client which
you can also install as an extension
from the chrome browser itself so if you
just if i just open the chrome browser
and it just say rest client if you just
write this and hit enter you will get
many different options and the first
option you get is from google play
stores app store so you can go to the
app store that basically the chrome web
store not the play store but the chrome
web store and you can just install this
since this is already installed you can
click on launch app and it will open
this interface for you so this is pretty
uh this is not a tutorial for advanced
rest client so i'll just be quick here
you can choose the method type which you
want to hit so let's say you want to do
a post and then you can provide the url
here so remember the url which we put
here in the controller method this has
to exactly match so http localhost slash
student slash create should be the url
so let me just copy paste this one here
okay so the url is good here it's a post
type of method which i want to do and i
want to hit this particular url now i
need to supply the content type and the
body so in the content type you can
choose application json because i'm
going to supply a json object and in the
body this is how the json object looks
like advanced risk client also provides
a nice visual interface to basically
create this json if you are thinking
that json creation is very tough it's
not actually tough it's just curly
braces and then you put key and value
key value comma let me just put an enter
here so that it's more readable so you
just put curly braces starting an end
and then you just put key value you put
a key which is the variable name and the
variables value variable name variable
value and these keys have to exactly
match the students properties so the
student.java had this name age and
address right so it has to exactly match
otherwise this will request will fail so
this is all good now i can send this
particular request when you click send
it is going to hit my spring boot
application which is running on
localhost 8080 it is going to call the
student slash create method it is also
going to convert this json into a java
object because here i am supplying a
java object so it will convert the json
which i'm sending from here to java
object automatically and it is going to
automatically save it here because i've
called the repository.save method so
let's hit send here once i hit send i
get a 200 okay it means everything went
fine and in the response header i get
the object back because i have returned
the object here you see this save method
is going to return the same student
object which you created uh so
everything is good here my object has
been stored here and now it's time to
fetch the object so it has already been
saved into the h2 in memory database and
you can obviously go and connect to the
in memory h2 database and have a look at
it but for simplicity i'm just going to
do this here and let's say the first
object is generally
added as the id1 by default by the h2
database so let's hit this particular
url when i hit this url it is going to
hit the student controller here and in
the student controller it is going to
hit the get student method which is
having a student id url and it is going
to find the database with that id and if
it finds a student object with that id
it is going to return that so let's
confirm that now let's hit this
particular send button and it is going
to hit a get request with this
particular url springboard is going to
find if a student with the id 1 exists
in its database
so once i hit send i get a 200 okay and
you see in the response headers i get
the same student object back which i
added let's try with 2 now let's see
what happens i see 2 and i get 500
internal server error because there is
no object stored in the h2 database of
the spring application with the id 2 yet
because we only inserted one object
that's why only one student object is
there and the first id which h2 database
created for it automatically was one so
when you hit for get request with a
student id one you get the object when
you put any invalid value and you hit
this you get a 500 internal server error
you can also make it look nice by not
sending the 500 internal server error
and sending a nice exception from the
back end so from here you can also send
a nice exception that if this object is
not found you can say something like
that or else throw which is again an
optional object and here you can supply
a particular type of exception which you
want to supply instead of just throwing
500 internal server error but that's
just additional thing additional
defensive programming you can do you can
add more and more validations and
constraints into this project as you
build this project in a more complex
paradigm so this is basically what i
wanted to show you that and that we have
created a spring up boot application we
have connected it to a database we
haven't created also an http endpoint
with student controller we ran that
application we used any random rest
client in my case i used advanced rest
client and we first did a post request
we provided the exact url the url has to
exactly match with the controller url
and then the body the request body also
has to exactly match with the student
objects property especially the case of
the names have to exactly match so if
this all this matches then you will get
a response back that the object has been
created if you want to fetch the value
of the object you are going to use the
http get method and you again provide a
url which has to exactly match to some
method in some controller in the spring
boot application which is running on
localhost and if you provide the right
id you are going to return get a valid
result if you provide an invalid id you
are going to get a 500 internal server
error and from here on you can make this
controller as robust and as mature as
you want you can add find all method you
can add update student method you can
add a delete student method you can have
all different kinds of filters like for
example return to me all the students
starting with the name a or return all
the first
students with the role number one and
100 or between 100 so you can write as
many end points as you want and build
this application in
as with as much maturity and as much
complexity as you want
we all know that java is one of the most
sought programming languages in the
current id industry there are multiple
multi-million dollar companies which are
using java till today
so this video is completely dedicated to
help out the java developers and the
beginners in java programming language
to crack the most frequently asked java
interview questions
so without further ado let's begin with
our interview questions
at first we will start with the beginner
level interview questions
so in the beginner level interview
questions the first question we have is
what is jit
so the answer for this question is
jit is an abbreviation for java in time
compiler it increases efficiency of the
interpreter by compiling the byte code
in the runtime
jit or just in time compiler compiles
code to machine level directly for
higher speeds of code execution
so basically just-in-time compilation is
a feature added to the interpreter of
java so this involves conversion of the
code directly to machine level during
the compilation stage this improvises
the speed of execution of a java program
now after the first question the second
question in the docket is
what is a class loader now let's discuss
the answer for this particular question
so basically class loader is the first
file to load when you execute any java
program so the java class loader is the
integrated part of java virtual machine
so the functionality of class loader is
to load the class to the java virtual
machine while it is demanded to execute
a class
java has both strap extension and
application type of class loaders
so the third question in the docket is
what are the memory allocations
available in java so the answer for this
particular question is
java provides multiple types of memory
allocations but the five major types of
memory allocations which are most
frequently used are class memory heap
memory stack memory program counter
memory native method stack memory
so the next question in the list is
will the program run if i write static
public void main so basically we write
public static word main but in case
imagine if i write the program as static
public void main will the program
execute properly so the answer for this
question is yes because java does not
follow any specific rule for the order
of specifiers you place in your program
so when you execute the program with
such pattern in your specifiers then the
program will compile successfully also
it will run successfully
so the next question we have is
what is the default value stored in
local variables
so in c programming language when you
declare a local variable or a global
variable or any type of variable
then the first value which is stored
inside that variable will be a garbage
value unless you initialize the variable
with a personalized value for example if
you declare a variable i equal to 0 then
you are storing a value in that variable
i that is 0. if you just declare it as
int i then the value stored inside that
i variable will be a garbage value so
similarly when you declare some kind of
local variable in java then what will be
the default value stored inside it
so the answer for this question is
neither the local variables or the
global variables or any primitives or
any object references do not have any
kind of default value stored in them
so followed by the fifth question we
have the sixth question
so what would be the output of the
following code segment is the sixth
question so this might happen sometimes
so basically what happens is your
interviewer will throw a question at you
which has a code segment so all you need
to do is decode that code in your mind
and provide the output so this would be
the code that we will be dealing with
so you can see
our question has two printf statements
the first one has 100 plus 100 plus a
string which is simply learn and in the
second printf statement we have a string
that is e-learning company plus 100 plus
100. so what will be the output of these
two printf statements
so the answer for this question is
really simple
so we'll be having 200 simply learn as
the first output and e-learning company
1 0 0 1 0 0 as the second output why
let's check out the code segment once
again
so when you see the code segment once
again so the first printf statement has
100 plus 100 plus simply learn so jvm
here understands 100 as an integer value
and the plus symbol as an addition
operator here so followed by the
addition operator we have another
integer value so what jvm does is it
adds the two numbers hundred plus 100 so
followed by that we have another plus
symbol here so followed by the plus
symbol we have a string value so here
the jvm considers the plus symbol as
a concatenating operator but not as an
addition operator so that's why the
first two numbers got added and the
result was 200 and the next two values
were concatenated so it became as 200
simply learned similarly in the second
printf statement the jvm encountered
with a string value
so it considered the plus symbol as a
concatenating operator similarly it
happened with the second plus symbol as
well so that's the reason we had
elearning one zero zero one zero zero as
the second output
now followed by the sixth question we
have the seventh question
what is an association
so the answer for this question is an
association can be defined as a
relationship that has no ownership over
the other so to understand this
definition we can consider a simple
example
consider a person associated with
multiple banks so consider person x who
has got accounts in bank a bank b and
bank c
and similarly a bank is associated with
person x
that is a bank a bank b and bank c are
associated with the person x but no one
has ownership over the other a person x
who is an account holder with all the
three banks that is a b and c does not
possess any kind of ownership over the
three banks similarly
banks a b and c who has the customer
which is the person x but the banks do
not possess any kind of ownership over
the customer
so the relationship between the person x
and the banks abc can be considered as
an association
now followed by the seventh question we
have the next question
that is the eighth question
define copy constructor and java so the
answer for this question is as follows
a copy constructor in java is a
constructor that initializes an object
through another object of the same class
a copy constructor in java is really
helpful because when you want to copy a
complex object that has several fields
or when we want to make a deep copy of
an existing object then the copy
constructor is the one which will help
you out in this situation
so followed by the eighth question we
have the ninth question
what is a marker interface
so the answer for this question is
an empty interface in java is referred
as a marker interface
serializable and cloneable are some of
the popular examples of marker interface
so basically a marker interface is just
another interface but normally in
interface we provide some signatures so
these signatures belong to particular
methods so
in normal interface we just have method
signatures but not the complete
implementation or at least we'll be
having some variables but in a marker
interface we do not have any kind of
data manipulating method signatures any
data members nothing they have special
functionality unlike a normal interface
so followed by the ninth question we
have the tenth question
what is object cloning
i guess the word object learning is
completely self-explanatory yet the
answer for this question is it is an
ability to recreate an object completely
similar to the existing object this
process is known as object cloning in
java
java provides a built-in function or
method that is the clone method to clone
an existing object offering the same
functionality that of the original
object
so followed by the 10th question we have
our 11th question
why is java not completely object
oriented
so this question might be a little
confusing but it's true java is not
completely object oriented but what's
the reason
yes i'll explain you why java is not
completely object oriented so the answer
for this question is java is not
considered as 100 object-oriented
programming language because of the data
types it uses
it still makes use of eight or more
primitive data types which are end flow
double and few others so this is the
only reason why java is not considered
as completely 100
object-oriented programming language so
the next question is
define wrapper classes in java
so the answer for this question is
in java when you declare primitive data
types that is the end flow double etc
then the wrapper classes are responsible
for converting them into objects or
reference types just as we discussed
before
java is not 100 object-oriented
programming language just because of the
primitive data types it uses so when you
include such primitive data types then
wrapper classes are the ones which
convert them into objects or reference
types for the ease of compilation and
execution of programs without any issues
so followed by this question we have the
next question
define singleton classes in java so the
answer for this question is in java when
you make the constructor of a class as
private then the particular class can
generate only one single object this is
the reason why such type of classes are
called as singleton classes
so followed by that we have our next
question that says define package in
java so if you use some of the popular
ides that is the integrated development
enterprises such as intellij or eclipse
then you might be familiar with projects
packages source files and then the class
file so basically you create a project
first and inside the project you will be
having your source folder and then you
will be creating your own package using
the source folder and inside the package
you will create a class file and inside
the class file is where you write your
java program so here the question is
define package in java
so the answer for this question is as
follows
package is a collective bundle of
classes and interfaces along with
necessary libraries and jar files
the use of packages helps in code
reusability so basically when you create
a specific package inside that package
you will store all the class files that
you will be using in your java program
so not only class files in case if you
use any kind of connectors or any kind
of jar files or any kind of dependencies
for your java program you will include
all those inside the package so that the
requirements and the class files are
bundled together and
this helps out in code reusability
making sure that the
program files or the java files or any
dependencies are not juggling between
one package to the other or one file to
the other so using a package is
basically a good practice
so followed by this we have our next
question
can you implement pointers in java
program
so if you remember
c programming language we had pointers
there
so we use pointers to directly access
the memory
so similarly can you use pointers in a
java program this is a little tricky
question for beginners but basically
it's really simple
now the answer for this question is
no
because java virtual machine personally
takes care of memory management
implicitly so java's major motive was to
keep programming simple so accessing
memory directly through pointers is not
a recommended action so the answer is a
big no you cannot implement pointers in
java program
so followed by that we have our next
question
differentiate between instance and local
variables
so the answer for this question is
really simple instance variables are
declared inside a class and the scope is
limited to only a specific object inside
which an instance variable is created so
followed by the instance variable we
have the local variable so the local
variable can be anywhere inside a method
or a specific block of code also the
scope is limited to the block of code
where the variable that is the local
variable is declared now followed by the
16th question we have our next question
explain java string pool so the answer
for this question is a collection of
strings in java's heap memory is
referred as java's string pool
so for example you wanted to create a
new string
consider your name so your name might be
some xyz so if you wanted to create xyz
string then you provide that particular
code to your jvm so what does jvm do it
will not directly create that particular
string first it will search for the xyz
string in your string pool if that is
already existing in your string pool
then it will provide a reference to that
particular string in case if xyz is not
there
then the jvm will create a new string
that is the xyz string
so followed by this we have our next
question that is
what is an exception
so the answer for this question is an
exception in java is considered as an
unexpected event that can disrupt the
normal flow of the program so for
example just consider that you are going
to write a program for division operator
so after you finish your program your
evaluator might want to test your code
to the extreme levels so instead of
providing a proper number imagine that
your evaluator is providing a wrong
input such as special symbols sometimes
0 or any other sort of input so if this
kind of input is provided to your
program
then your program might crash so you can
avoid this kind of crash by using
exception handling so basically you can
use try and catch blocks so you can
embed your code inside the try block and
say to your program that if any kind of
wrong input such as special symbol or 0
is provided by the evaluator then send a
message saying wrong input or divide by
0 exception so this kind of approach
will provide an output but this kind of
approach will avoid your program from
crashing so this is how exceptions are
handled in real time so followed by this
we have our next question
what is final keyword in java
so the answer for this question is the
term final is a predefined word in java
that is used while declaring values to
variables when a value is declared using
the final keyword then that particular
value of that particular variable
will remain constant throughout the
execution of program so sometimes if you
include a normal variable and provide an
operation on that particular variable
then the value of that particular
variable will change after the execution
of program but when you declare the same
variable using final keyword then no
number of operations or any kind of
manipulations applied onto that variable
will not change the value of that
particular variable so that's a
speciality of final keyword in java so
followed by that we'll dive into the
next question that is
what happens when the main method is not
declared as static
so the answer for this question is
when the main method is not declared a
static then the program may be compiled
perfectly but ends up with a serious
ambiguity and throws a runtime error
that says
no such method error
so when you basically declare a main
method don't forget to specify the
static keyword
so with this we finish the beginner
segment of questions followed by the
beginners segment we have the next
segment that is the intermediate level
segment
so the first question in the
intermediate level is
what is jdk and mention the variance of
jdk
so the answer for this question is
so jdk is basically an abbreviation for
java development kit
this is a combined package of jre that
is the java runtime environment and
developer tools used for designing java
applications and applets
oracle has the following variants for
java development kit so the first one is
the jdk standard edition which is
normally used by beginners and
intermediate developers
next after the jdk standard edition we
have the java development kit for
enterprise
so this particular enterprise edition is
used by professional java developers for
developing java based applications and
frameworks
now the last one is the java development
kit micro edition
now followed by 21st question we will
dive into the next question that says
brief access specifiers and types of
access specifiers in java so the answer
for this question is as follows
basically access specifiers are
predefined keywords used to help a java
virtual machine to understand the scope
of a particular data member or data
manipulating method within a class or
outside the class so in java we have
four types of access specifiers the
first one is public access specifier so
when you declare a data member or a data
manipulating method as public then that
particular data member or method can be
accessible by any class or object
throughout the package
followed by that we have the private
access specifier so unlike the public
access specifier when you provide the
private access specifier then the
accessibility of that particular private
data member or the data manipulating
method will be provided to specific
classes and specific objects only and
finally we have the protected access
specifier so the protected access
specifier is a bit more secure than the
private access specifier so the access
for this particular protected data
member or protected data manipulating
method could be a little more difficult
to access unless you are going to
implement everything which is present in
that particular package
so basically if you are trying to access
the protected data member or protected
data manipulating method
of a different package then you need to
first import the package into your
existing package so that's how the
protected access specifier works
practically so finally after the major
three axis specifiers we have the
default access specifier so default
access specifier will be provided by the
java virtual machine so in case if you
declare a variable or a data
manipulating method without using any
specific access specifiers that are
public private and protected then jvm
implicitly considers the default access
specifier so there is no much of a
difference between the public access
specifier and the default access
specifier both have the same
functionality and accessibility so
followed by this question we enter into
the next question that is
can a constructor written a value
so the answer for this question is as
follows
yes
a constructor can written a value it
basically returns the current instance
of a class implicitly you cannot make a
constructor written a value explicitly
but
automatically it returns the instance of
a class
so the next question is explain this
keyword in java so in java we do have a
keyword which is called as this so what
does the keyword this mean in java is a
question
so the answer for this question is the
term this is a special keyword
designated as a reference variable so
the term this keyword is used to refer
to the current class properties like
data manipulating method instance data
member and constructors so followed by
the 24th question we have our next
question that says
explain
super keyword in java so the answer for
this question is as follows
the term super is a special keyword
designated as a reference variable so
similar to this keyword even super
keyword acts as a reference variable but
the difference is super keyword is used
to refer to the immediate parent class
object so followed by the 25th question
we have our next question
that is explain method overloading in
java so basically method overloading and
method overriding etc are the concepts
of polymorphism so now let's have a
correct answer here so the process of
creating multiple method signatures
using one method name is called as
method overloading
so for example consider that you wanted
to include an addition operation in your
program that performs addition operation
so the first method will be having the
name add and inside the method
parameters you will be having two
integer types of parameters similarly
you wanted to perform another addition
operation with the same name add so here
you will provide the method name
completely same to the first method but
inside the parameters there is a
difference
you are adding
three parameters here
so when you pass the values to the add
method
then which method to be overloaded
that's the confusion right so should i
overload or should i execute the first
add method or the second word method so
this completely depends on the number of
parameters you pass if you are passing
two parameters then the first method
will be executed if you are passing
three parameters then the second method
will be executed so this is how the
method overloading happens in java
so
the process of method overloading can be
achieved by using two different ways the
first way is to change the number of
arguments so that's what exactly i've
discussed before now the second way is
varying the written type of the method
so with this let's enter into the next
question
can we overload a static method
so as discussed before the values of the
variables or data manipulating methods
will not be changed when we have used
the keyword static in front of it so the
question is can we overload a static
method now let's discuss the answer for
this
the answer is no java does not support
overloading of static method
the process worked through an error
reading static method cannot be
referenced so followed by this we have
our next question
so the next question is define
late binding the answer for this
question is
binding is a process of unifying the
method call with the methods code
segment
late binding happens when the methods
code segment is unknown till the method
is called during the runtime
so followed by this we have our next
question define dynamic method dispatch
so the answer is the dynamic method
dispatch is a process where the method
call is executed during the runtime the
overridden method is called through a
reference variable of superclass so this
process is called as runtime
polymorphism
now we have our next question
why is delete function faster in
linkedlist than an array
so basically linked list and array are
the java collections or in other words
it's also considered as data structure
so to answer this question you need to
understand the analogy of linked list
and array so basically an array is um
complete memory block of consecutive
memory locations so consider that your
memory location starts from 100 and your
array has 10 locations so it's a
complete reserved block of from 100 101
102 to 1.9
so you have 10 memory blocks so in case
if you wanted to add a number or a
delete a number then you had to make
changes to the complete memory block but
when you come into linked list
you have
the memory blocks used from the memory
heap so basically what you do here is
you basically connect the nodes through
addresses
so in case if you wanted to eliminate a
number then what you do is just to
manipulate the addresses so the address
of the consecutive node will be changed
so that's the only change what you make
so now
this is the reason why the
delete function or any kind of
manipulation function is faster in
linked list compared to array
so now let's have a brief answer on this
delete function is faster in linked list
as the user needs to make a minor update
to the point of value so that the node
can point to the next successor in the
list
now followed by this we have our next
question
give a briefing on the life cycle of a
thread
so the life cycle of a thread includes
five stages which are as mentioned below
newly born state runnable state that is
it provides the jvm with a feedback that
i'm ready to run now followed by that
the running stage where the threat is
actually running followed by that the
block stage so basically the thread will
be blocked for some reasons for some
intermediate output or something if the
thread is waiting for an input from
another source or
something similar so that's where the
blocked state comes to existence and
finally the dead state once after
everything is processed the thread is
eliminated by gvm
now followed by this we have our next
question that says
explain the differences between
the operators provided here
so the operators might look similar but
they are different now let's understand
about these operators in a much better
way through the answer so the answer for
this question is although they look
similar but there's a huge difference
between them so the first operator which
looks like two greater than symbols
performed the operation of right
shifting so when you provide a binary
number or binary value then the bits
will be shifted towards the right and
the second symbol or the second operator
which is having three greater than
symbols is used to shift out the zero
filled bits so this is the functionality
of these two operators now followed by
that let's have the 33rd question
brief the life cycle of an applet
so the answer for this question is the
life cycle of an applet basically
involves the following stages the first
stage is the initialization stage next
is the start stage third is the stop
stage fourth is destroy and finally we
have paint
now the next question is why are
generics used in java
so the answer for this question is
compile time type safety is provided by
using generics in java so this approach
allows the users to catch unnecessary
invalid inputs at the time of
compilation
generic methods and classes help
programmers to specify a single method
declaration a set of related methods or
with a single class declaration a set of
related types
so followed by this we have our next
question
explain
externalizable interface
so the answer for this question is the
externalizable interface helps with the
control over the process of
serialization the externalization
interface incorporates read external and
right external methods so we have
listened to a new term here which is
serialization so what exactly is
serialization
serialization is a process of sending
your java code or java project from one
computer system to a different computer
system so basically if you wanted to
execute some kind of java program from a
different location then you serialize
this particular code to a different
location where you actually want to
execute and this particular process of
transferring your code is called as
serialization
now the next question is explain daemon
thread so the answer for this question
is the daemon thread can be defined as a
thread with least responsibility the
daemon thread is designed to run in a
background during the process of garbage
collection in java
the set daemon method is used to create
the demon thread in java programming
language
so we have our next question now explain
the term enumeration in java
so the answer for this question is
enumeration or enum is an interface in
java enum allows the sequential access
of elements stored in a collection in
java now the next question is
why is java considered as a dynamic
programming language
so the answer for this question is java
was designed to adapt to an evolving
environment java programs include large
amount of runtime information that is
actually used to resolve access to the
objects in real time so this is a reason
why java is considered as dynamic
programming language
now followed by this we have our next
question
can you run a code before executing the
main method
so the answer for this question is
yes we can execute any code even before
the main method
we will be using the static block of
code in the class when creating the
objects at load time of the class any
statements within the static block of
the code will execute it once while
loading the class even before the
creation of objects in the main method
now the last question in the
intermediate section is how many times
the finalized method is called
so the answer for this question is the
finalized method is called by the
garbage collector so for every object
the garbage collector calls the finalize
method just for once
now with this let's enter the advanced
segment of interview questions based on
java
so the first question in the advanced
segment is
can the keywords this and super we used
together
so the answer for this question is
no
this and super keywords should be used
in the first statement in the class
constructor so the following code
segment will give you a better idea
so you can see that we have used the
keyword super and this in the class
constructor that is the first class
constructor
now this is how you can use super
keyword and this keyword together in
case if you wanted to use
so with this let's continue with the
next question in the advanced level
so the next question says explain jsp
page so the answer for this question is
jsp is basically an abbreviation for
java servlet page so the java servlet
page consists of two types of text the
first is the static data and the second
one is java servlet page elements
now the next question is
explain jd bc so the answer is jdbc is
an abbreviation for java database
connector jdbc is an abstract layer used
to establish connectivity between any
existing database and to a java
application
next question is
explain the various directives of jsp
so the directives are instructions
processed by jsp engine after the jsp
page is compiled into a servlet
directives are used to set page level
instructions
insert data from external files and
specify custom tag libraries directives
are defined between the following
symbols
so these are the symbols that are used
to specify the directives in a jsp page
the different types of directives are
shown as below there are three types of
directives they are include directive
page directive and tagleb directive so
include directive includes a file and
merges the content of the file with the
current page
the page directive is used to define
specific attributes in the jsp page like
error page and buffer the taglib
directory is used to declare a custom
tag library which is used in the jsp
page
followed by that we have the next
question
what are observer and observable classes
so the answer for this question is
objects that subclass the observable
class maintain a list of observers when
an observable object is updated it
invokes the update method of each of the
observers to notify that the observers
that it has changed its state
the observer interface is implemented by
objects that observe observable objects
might be a little confusing but you need
to read this answer once again you can
pause it and you can read this answer
once again so that you can get a brief
understanding of this
followed by that we have the next
question
what is session management in java so
the answer for this question is
a session is essentially defined as the
dynamic stage of a random conversation
between the client and the server the
essential communication channel includes
the string of responses and requests
from both sides typically the most
popular way of implementing session
management is the employment of a
session id in the communicative
discourse of the client and the server
the next question is brief about spring
framework spring framework is basically
the framework of frameworks now the
answer for this question is spring is
essentially defined as the application
framework and inversion of control
container for java basically the chief
purpose of spring framework is to create
enterprise applications in java also it
is especially useful to keep in mind
that the central features of the spring
framework are essentially conductive to
any java application
so the next question is explain jca in
java so the answer for this question is
jca is basically an abbreviation for
java cryptography architecture
so jca provides a platform that gives
architecture and apis for encryption as
well as decryption
jc is used by the developer to combine
the application with the security
measure it also helps in performing the
third party security rules it uses the
hash table encryption message digest etc
to implement the security so the next
question is
explain jpa in java so the answer for
this question is
jpa stands as an abbreviation for java
persistence api the jpa is enabling us
to create the persistence layer for
desktop and web applications
jpa deals with the following
java persistence api query language java
persistence criteria api object mapping
metadata etc
so the last question in our list is
explain the different authentications in
java servlets
so the answer for this question is
authentication options available in
servlets are as follows the first one is
basic authentication so the basic
authentication consists of username and
password provided by the client to
authenticate as the user the second one
is form based authentication
in this particular type of
authentication the login form is made by
the programmer by using html
followed by that we have the third type
of authentication that is digest
authentication
digest authentication is similar to
basic authentication but in this the
passwords are encrypted using hash
formula
this makes digest more secured and
lastly we have the client certificate
authentication the client certificate
authentication requires that each client
accessing the resource has a certificate
that it sends to authenticate itself
this requires
ssl protocol now with that we have come
to an end of the session on java
projects and java interview questions
hope this session was helpful and if you
have any queries regarding any of the
topics covered in this session or if you
require the resources that we used in
this session then please feel free to
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of experts will get back to
you at the earliest and try to resolve
all your queries as soon as possible
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here